j'ouvre le second débat de ce sens
public consacré à la guerre en Ukraine
plus précisément au rôle de la milice
Wagner et de son chef evegaini prix
gaugine combien d'hommes quel rôle dans
la stratégie de défense russe face à la
contre-offensive ukrainienne quel lien
avec Vladimir Poutine et l'Etat russe
avant dans des battre on vous explique
ce qu'est Wagner avec Cécile
en Afrique puis totalement avec le
conflit ukrainien mais cette armée de
mercenaires créée par l'homme d'affaires
evguni Prigogine existe depuis 10 ans
cette ministreuse c'est d'abord déployée
en Ukraine en 2014 lors de l'annexion de
la Crimée elle s'implant ensuite de
façon fulgurante en Afrique où selon
cette journaliste du Monde le groupe
promet protection aux dirigeants
africains ils sont arrivés dans
d'innombrables pays africains le
Mozambique la Libye le Burkina Faso le
enfin il y en a beaucoup beaucoup et
donc on échange de cette protection pour
pour certains dirigeants ou certaines
castes de de de ces pays africains et
bien il prélève des richesses naturelles
dans ces pays et donc là efghani a
privilégié a constituer un empire une
infusion silencieuse avec son groupe
Wagner evgny Prigogine crée des zones
d'influence russe en Afrique sans jamais
intervenir par les bois officielles
toujours avec beaucoup de violences
sanctionnés par l'Union européenne à
plusieurs reprises le groupe est
qualifié d'organisation terroristes par
plusieurs pays dont la France nous avons
c'est un groupe de mercenaires criminels
c'est ainsi qu'il est objectivement
qualifié et ma conviction c'est que les
différents états africains y compris
ceux qui se sont tournés vers cette
solution de court terme
finiront par s'en passer
parce qu'elle ne s'aime que le malheur
là où elle se déploie
en 2022 cette armée de l'ombre prend
tout sa dimension avec l'invasion russe
en Ukraine Eve Guny primogen ne se cache
plus et même une guerre de l'information
via les réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui à midi
plusieurs 00 bark mout a été prise dans
sa totalité
son groupe Wagner aurait recruté près de
40 000 soldats russes supplémentaires
pour combattre sur le solucréien à
travers cette ce déploiement en fait en
Ukraine il a employé une méthode qui a
fait couler beaucoup d'encre à juste
titre parce qu'il a recruté dans les
prisons ou dans les hôpitaux
psychiatriques et donc il a recruté ce
qu'on appelle de la chiracano pour pour
combattre les forces ukrainiennes
officiellement interdit en Russie cette
armée travaillerait officieusement pour
Poutine de quoi entretenir la
concurrence avec l'armée russe kefguny
pregojin critique ouvertement l'homme
d'affaires aurait des ambitions
politiques à plus long terme
l'origine du groupe Wagner sont
financement les horreurs commises par
les hommes des ministres Wagner sur les
différents terrains de guerre où ils
sont engagés voilà les multiples thèmes
de notre débat avec Christine dumouin
Clément bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
chercheur pour la chair risqué
l'observatoire de l'intelligence à Paris
1 Lucas Obama bonsoir bienvenue à vous
aussi directeur de recherche à l'IRIS
spécialiste de la géopolitique de la
Russie d'ailleurs c'est le titre de
votre livre géopolitique de la Russie la
rue aux éditions La Découverte j'accue
également Alexandre Jousset bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes journaliste
réalisatier triste du documentaire
Wagner l'armée de l'ombre de Poutine
avec Sénia bolchakova produit par Cap
après vous travaillez encore aujourd'hui
et documentaire qui a été récompensé par
le Prix Albert Londres en 2022 dans la
catégorie audiovisuelle et Mathieu
croissando éditoris politiques est resté
à mes côtés on va rester pour commencer
sur quand même l'actualité de cette
contre-offensive ukrainienne Christine
Dubois Clément est-ce qu'on sait ou
combattre les vilis Wagner en ce moment
est-ce qu'ils sont toujours autour de de
backgroute quel rôle il joue face à
cette contre-offensive est-ce qu'elle
sait ça alors ce qu'il faut bien savoir
c'est qu'à l'heure actuelle on a une
relative asymétrie informationnelle
c'est à dire que l'Ukraine communique
assez peu la Russie communique beaucoup
et que évidemment ce qui vient en
communication de la Russie est toujours
à prendre avec beaucoup de pincettes et
prendre le temps de la vérification
donc ça c'est quelque chose qui est
extrêmement important quant à Wagner
donc qui est et ça aussi je pense qu'il
faut il faut bien le préciser c'est une
des sociétés et un des groupes de
mercenaires parmi beaucoup d'autres qui
sont qui sont sur le terrain il y a eu
des annonces de trilogie qui ont fait
couler encore beaucoup d'encre en
annonçant que peut-être ils se
replierait que finalement les choses
n'avançaient pas aussi aussi bien que
prévu pour le côté russe donc on a une
certaine prudence dans le dans l'art
déclaratoire notamment parce que ça
permet aussi de s'inscrire dans
offensive qui part nature sera longue
on parle souvent de de brouillard de
guerre c'est ce que c'est ce que nous
disait Christine ou un Clément c'est
très difficile d'avoir des informations
fiables on est en plein dedans on est en
plein dans le brouillard de guerre là ah
oui complètement oui en ce moment c'est
la définition même peut-être du
brouillard de guerre on sait que du côté
évidemment
ukrainien on a ce symbole c'est ce clip
qui est passé où on voit des soldats
Ukrainiens justement faire un symbole
chute pour dire justement il ne faut pas
parler plus cette des informations ne
seront pas donné mieux on aura de chance
de réussir et c'est un message aux
populations aussi de ne pas publier une
vidéo et ou d'informations exactement et
du côté russe à l'inverse effectivement
on parle beaucoup c'est d'ailleurs c'est
c'est un contraste c'est assez marquant
c'est-à-dire que on voit effectivement
les chaînes d'information continue qui
continue d'alimenter le débat qui disent
que au contraire cette contre-offensive
a déjà débuté et que elle serait déjà
elle aurait déjà échoué en réalité et
que finalement on préparerait déjà la
contre contre-offensive du côté russe
évidemment d'un côté comme de l'autre il
faut se méfier des informations en ce
moment et au contraire essayer justement
de garder disons j'allais dire notre
sang-froid puisque le temps de
l'hystérie entre guillemets médiatique
ne va pas forcément de pair avec le
temps du brouillard de gaz alors selon
la Maison Blanche revient plus
précisément à la mise Wagner elle compte
50 000 mercenaires en Ukraine donc 40
000 recrutés dans les prisons russes
mais Alexandra Jousset beaucoup ne
reviendront jamais du crânes qu'on sait
combien il y a eu de morts au sein de la
bise Wagner est-ce que ça fait partie
aussi de la de la communication
justement de son chef avec
galliprigogine les morts il les a mis en
scène on les a vu dans certaines vidéos
qu'il a publié sur telegram justement
pour récupérer pour essayer de réclamer
plus d'armes de la part parce que evgami
Prigogine a un bras de fer avec le
ministre de la Défense Sergueï chouï et
il dit que Serge soyou ne lui fournit
pas les armes parce que il veut
l'empêcher de réussir ses offensives et
du coup dans cette lutte
informationnelle que l'on appelle tout
ça des vidéos de propagande donc il met
en scène les centaines dizaines on a vu
vraiment de cadavres de cercueil donc
oui les a utilisés en revanche combien
il y a de morts je c'est presque
impossible de le savoir on est toujours
dans ce brouillard et puis en fait tous
les chiffres sont à prendre avec des
pincettes on sait pas les 50.000 on sait
pas vraiment exactement personne est
vraiment capable de mesurer combien ils
étaient avant combien ils sont depuis il
y a des estimations mais aujourd'hui
combien ils sont encore combien ils sont
morts en tout cas moi j'ai pas cette
information donc on reste prudent aux
prisonniers parce qu'il est donc ce
recrutement dans les prisons Christine
ou un Clément il promettaient 2500
dollars mensuels l'amnistie au bout de
six mois est-ce que est-ce qu'il y a une
grille de salaire je vais pardon c'est
ça semble un peu trivial mais est-ce
qu'il y a une grille de salaire chez les
les soldats de la des différentes
milices Wagner en fonction des des pays
où ils interviennent on a même eu
différents
chez vous avez des documents qui sont
sortis qui ont été publiés
en fonction de la zone où vous allez
envoyer les mercenaires c'est à dire que
c'est pas les mêmes profils pour les
gens qui cherchent à rentrer dans Wagner
ou à renouveler un contrat parce que il
y a aussi des renouvellements de
contrats qui vont aller sur la zone du
Moyen-Orient ou sur la zone africaine et
ceux qui vont aller en Ukraine on
cherche pas les mêmes profils on cherche
pas les mêmes compétences les salaires
et les primes ne sont pas les mêmes
typiquement on est moins exigeant en
terme de compétences sur les profils qui
vont aller en Ukraine là où on va
beaucoup plus demander des formateurs de
formateurs par exemple pour certains
certains pays africains et par contre on
va avoir des demandes du type de ne pas
avoir de famille en Ukraine ou à
l'étranger hors pays de la COI donc en
Occident pour ne pas être sous pression
ou avoir des influences ça c'est ce qui
était demandé au début au bout d'un
moment nécessité finit par faire loi il
y avait aussi des demandes relatives à
l'état de santé
donc sur des infections des infections
virales etc donc oui vous avez
effectivement des grilles mais toutes
les sociétés militaires privées en fin
de compte sont des sociétés comme enfin
comme les autres
économiquement comme les autres donc
vous avez pas oublié ça on l'a pas
encore dit c'est du business c'est la
guerre et c'est du business c'est pas
que ça dans le cadre de Wagner puisque
on a quand même une imbrication complexe
avec le pouvoir et que Prigogine alors
que l'on voit beaucoup sur le devant de
la scène faut pas oublier d'où il vient
ses premières activités étaient dans la
restauration date de 97 mais il a
beaucoup beaucoup travaillé dans tout ce
qui était opération informationnelle et
de communication vous avez des agences
de de presse et des agences de
production comme au rhum qui vont même
produire des films type touristes granit
etc qui mettent en scène les hommes de
Wagner comme étant comme sauvant par
exemple des partis politiques donc vous
avez tous là et Wagner est estimé comme
une finalement une petite partie de
l'empire économique de frigor quand vous
regardez l'ensemble de ces activités
beaucoup sont liées à des activités du
pouvoir quand vous remportez des marchés
publics pour de la restauration publique
pour des sommes qui sont extrêmement
importantes vous avez un lien vous ne
pouvez difficilement aller recruter dans
les prisons alors même si ça a changé
depuis le temps sans avoir une
validation et quand à
Poutine a longtemps dit qu'il y avait
aucun lien on y reviendra là il y a
certains hommes ont été rendus
effectivement à la vie civile et
certains ont bénéficié de cette Amnesty
alors encore une fois maintenant il est
difficile au jour d'aujourd'hui d'avoir
des informations précises mais on en a
eu et encore une fois l'amnistie ne peut
pas être donné par une société privée
mais bien avec avec la bénédiction du
pouvoir
ça se paye est-ce que le Kremlin paye
Wagner et si oui combien est-ce qu'on le
sait Alexandra je sais moi j'ai eu des
informations non corroborées par
certains services que que
le Kremlin aurait payé un moment Wagner
mais en fait ça peut passer par d'autres
contrats comme Wagner travail aussi sur
les cantines scolaires les les cantines
de l'armée enfin c'est une façon de
financer exactement ce que j'allais dire
c'est que en fait c'est surtout qu'on
lui a demandé de financer parce que
c'est lui qui a récupéré des énormes
contrats comme vous le disiez des
cantines scolaires des cantines de
l'armée et que en fait c'est un service
qu'on lui a demandé en disant tu te
finances on te fait on te finance
grassement et en échange je suivais
Wagner et puis surtout tu as le droit de
te servir sur la bête ça c'est aussi
quelque chose qui est très important
c'est à dire que c'est pas ça qui le
fait vivre mais tout l'exploitation des
minerais en Centrafrique en au Mali
évidemment énormément en Syrie il faut
pas oublier que c'est en Syrie va sa
filiale et brocolis que Evelyne pringyne
a gagné beaucoup d'argent sur la
sécurisation des puits de pétrole dont
il prend 25% en fait l'idée c'est qui
sécurise depuis le pétrole et il prend
25% des recettes de ces puits de pétrole
donc oui là-dessus il arrive à gagner de
l'argent même si on pense que finalement
c'est pas avec ces missions de
mercenaria qui gagne de l'argent mais
c'est vraiment que les contrats qu'il a
réussi à récupérer par le gouvernement
russe en fait alors vous le disiez il y
a plusieurs milices on va le détailler
tout de suite grâce à Jonathan Dupriez
ce qui doit être juste derrière le
magnifique rideau noir de sens public
bonsoir je l'attends reçois
on voit émerger effectivement d'autres
sociétés qui pourraient peu à peu
concurrencer Wagner et puis c'est même
le renseignement militaire britannique
qui affirme le Kremlin voudrait je cite
parrainer développer des sociétés
militaires alternatives à Wagner devenu
sans doute trop puissante et surtout en
rupture avec Vladimir Poutine depuis des
mois le patron de la milice est venu
Prigogine que vous avez cité critique
ouvertement l'armée russe et n'est plus
en odeur de santé à Moscou le Kremlin
cherche donc à diversifier ses
sous-traitants et cela bien sûr
aiguisent les appétits de petites
sociétés qui veulent grignoter des parts
de marché avec nerf alors qui sont les
concurrents éventuels de Wagner en
Ukraine alors il y en a plusieurs elle
s'appelle patriote Sewa services ou
encore convoy qu'on voit je sais pas
comment on prononce je m'arrête sur
celle-ci qui est présenté comme une
concurrente sérieuse à Wagner elle est
née fin 2022 avec à sa tête le
gouverneur de la Crimée occupée cette
société elle opère principalement là-bas
dans le sud de l'Ukraine vers la ville
de Kerson et quand voï et bien elle
recrute via des boucles telegrammes sur
la messagerie télégram et les profils
recherchés ils sont assez simples c'est
des hommes jusqu'à 60 ans ayant
idéalement une expérience militaire rien
de bien différent finalement que Wagner
vivier reste celui des voilà des anciens
militaires pourquoi pas des prisonniers
et plusieurs sources parlent d'une
rémunération autour de 2500 dollars par
mois aussi les fourchettes que vous
évoquiez un peu plus tôt sur ce plateau
donc l'effectif de canevoy du peu
condensé en tout cas serait encore très
limité à ce stade on voit des chiffres
circulaient de 300 membres actuellement
contre 50000 peut-être pour Wagner elle
a encore on n'est pas sûr est-ce qu'on
peut parler d'une privatisation toujours
plus grande de la guerre côté R
c'est principalement de Wagner en tout
cas c'est une tentative de mise au pas
c'est ça la principale information je
crois c'est-à-dire Queen Prigogine
depuis plusieurs mois effectivement
affective régulièrement les corps
intermédiaires en Russie l'état-major
russe rarement directement Vladimir
Poutine c'est important quand même et
effectivement on a la sensation parfois
que c'est un peu comme si la créature de
Frankenstein finalement c'est s'échapper
échapper à son créateur entre guillemets
et donc il faut tenter de le mettre au
pas en tout cas c'est à quelque chose
essaie de faire ça en ce moment il
aurait la valve de Vladimir Poutine je
dis bien il aurait parce que encore une
fois on est dans un temps assez court
donc attention aux informations qui
circulent après la question désormais
c'est de savoir s'il va accepter cette
mise au pas s'il ne va pas au contraire
prendre des libertés les tarus semble
parfois un peu
instable même si c'est très difficile de
tirer des conclusions à ce stade mais
quand la Russie est attaqué directement
sur son territoire notamment à Belgorod
et qu'elle a des difficultés à repousser
ses assauts on peut légitimement douter
de sa capacité militaire finalement à
contenir aussi une milice privée comme
celle de oui alors il y a une autre
dimension Cristiano et Clémence
c'est-à-dire que est-ce que la
multiplication de milices comme ça
privée ça rend l'armée russe moins
efficace moins coordonnées est-ce qu'on
peut dire ça ou pas alors il y a
effectivement un enjeu de coordination
cela dit il y a déjà eu un travail pour
mieux coordonner les opérations y
compris avec Wagner pendant l'hiver on
l'a vu ou finalement il y avait des
opérations qui semblaient réellement
coordonnées entre les forces régulières
pilotées par le ministère de la Défense
russe et Wagner comme d'autres unités
ce qui est notable alors il y avait déjà
eu des bruits comme quoi il y aurait eu
des tentatives de réintégrer Wagner au
ministère de la Défense il y avait eu
des réunions qui avaient fuité à
Saint-Pétersbourg sur le sujet où est le
siège tout en discrétion d'ailleurs de
Wagner si vous avez des images du
bronchique
mais
sur rue ce qui est aussi intéressant
c'est que là il y a une demande de
légalisation des SMP ce qui est juste là
n'était pas le cas donc on voit que bon
on dit ok on va les réintégrer sous
couvert la société militaire privée sous
couvert de pouvoir donner un statut à
ces mercenaires etc donc l'idée c'est un
petit peu salade donc vous vous
présentez comme étant défenseur de ces
de ces gens là ça vous donne aussi quand
même le moyen de récupérer et de mieux
coordonner des forces qui vous
permettent de renforcer vos unités sans
avoir appel à faire appel à une
mobilisation ou à ce genre de choses à
ce titre là alors on a parlé de
l'opinion publique russe
il y en a d'autres réduites si on est de
l'ordre de 7000 et il y a des petits
groupes qui sont assez intéressants
enfin qu'elle est pas top notamment qui
sont soupçonnés comme étant très liés à
la société gaz promise qui participerait
à en financer une partie ou du moins à
les aider de manière relative ça vous ça
veut dire tout simplement que ça vous
fait un autre moyen de récupérer de
récupérer des hommes donc vous avez tout
ça si vous voulez qu'il joue et
effectivement ce qui serait intéressant
ce sera de voir quel sera la position de
prix d'origine en oubliant pas qu'il y a
un deuxième intérêt c'est de faire ce
que l'on va appeler une montée de la
pression horizontale notamment sur les
Occidentaux c'est à dire d'agiter des
foyers de déstabilisation sur d'autres
parties le continent africain est un
très bon exemple en Afrique de l'Ouest
on l'a vu on a vu Wagner intervenir dans
les Balkans il se déploie aussi en
Amérique latine donc on a on a aussi
d'autres choses comme ça et ça peut être
un jeu de dire bah écoutez on rentre
relativement dans le rang et puis on va
aller
ré-affoler d'autres zones alors on va
remonter aux origines à source du groupe
Wagner en prenant un premier extrait de
votre documentaire Alexandra Jousset on
y découvre pourquoi le fondateur de la
miss qui s'appelle Dimitri outkine a
choisi ce nom de Wagner
Dimitri woodkin un vétéran des forces
spéciales russes
dans l'armée russe pourquoi un tel
surnom parce qu'il serait un grand
admirateur d'Hitler et de toute la
symbolique nazie il a des tatouages
inspirés du Troisième Reich et de
l'esthétique fasciste
[Musique]
entièrement à cette idéologie
de la compagnie militaire privée Wagner
depuis 2014 10000 hommes aurait servi
sous ses ordres
Alexandra joue c'est comment trigogi
est-il devenu le chef de Wagner et
est-ce que il a une idéologie ou pas
d'ailleurs est-ce que il y a comme pour
le fondateur de de la ministre du groupe
voilà un fond idéologique en plus il a
un fond idéologique ça c'est sûr tous
les gens qui ont travaillé avec lui
alors je dirais pas un fond idéologique
pro nazi comme comme Dimitri hutchine en
tout cas en tout cas
pro russe et pour le retour de la Grande
Russie la Russie impériale la ruse
blanche tsariste le pouvoir fort
centralisé ça c'est indéniable et
d'ailleurs je pense qu'il faut pas
minimiser la part de lier de logis dans
l'engagement des prix gaugines on parle
toujours de ces entrepreneurs
d'influence du business autour de Wagner
du fait que c'est une mafia c'est une
mafia mais il y va de bon coeur quoi
quand il organise les campagnes de
désinformation sur les élections
américaines ce qu'on va en parler Wagner
et Prigogine pas que les mercenaires
c'est aussi des informations
c'est une machine de propagande et des
informations et ça il le fait parce que
idéologiquement il y croit et
idéologiquement il est opposé à
l'Occident et nous les les Mercières de
Wagner qu'on a rencontré sur le terrain
les commandants à qui on a pu parler il
nous disait on veut détruire l'Occident
c'est à dire que c'était très clair
c'était c'était une guerre idéologique
ce que je veux dire c'est pour ça que je
dis il faut faire attention aux nazisme
parler avec nazisme oui le commandant il
a et c'est pour ça qu'on l'appelle
Wagner maintenant le reste des des
combattants Wagner c'est encore plus
pour pour cette idéologie prorogique
comment il prend le pouvoir au sein de
Wagner il est poussé par par le Kremlin
c'est oui alors nous dans les Wagner le
X il y avait un document qui nous a qui
nous a passionné c'était un document qui
est émanait des services et de gagner le
prix gaugine
pour qui adressé au ministère de la
Défense et au FSB et qui racontait en
fait l'historique de Wagner et qui
disait mais voilà en Dimitri hooking est
arrivé en 2013 2014 ensuite on a fait
comme nous avait dit on a pris
l'aéroport de lougan ce qu'on a fait
tous les tous les coups de feu et en
fait on voit que c'est à ce moment-là
que Prigogine est nommé à la tête où on
lui demande de financer en fait de faire
passer ce groupe d'un petit groupe de
mercenaires d'anciens du GERU a vraiment
une véritable armée et de mettre tout
son argent au service de cette cause là
et donc en fait on pense pas enfin une
fois de plus ça demande encore plus
d'être vérifié d'être étayé mais on ne
pense pas que ce soit l'idée de gagner
Prigogine à la base en revanche on pense
que on lui a fortement conseillé en
échange des contrats qu'il avait et s'il
voulait continuer à recevoir des
contrats de financer Wagner et de le
financer très largement
si vous voulez c'est quand on parle des
autres groupes de mercenaires il y en a
plein des groupes de mercenaires avec
300 combattants c'est pas des groupes
c'est pas des armées c'est pas des
institutions ils sont pas organisées
pris d'origine c'est vraiment le le
mauvais génie créatif derrière c'est un
homme très intelligent c'est un homme
qui a compris le sens du marketing c'est
un homme qui qui a pensé toutes ces
stratégies qui crée un empire et il crée
un empire
des mercenaires de Wagner qu'on a
interviewé il était tous les jours dans
le bureau et qui a gagné prix gaugine à
regarder les cartes des offensives en
Syrie et il y avait Dimitri à côté de
lui mais c'est Prigogine qui dirigeait
les opérations et en fait outkins si
vous voulez c'est une commandant mais
c'est un militaire enfin je veux pas me
conseiller ce que je veux dire c'est que
c'est vraiment un exécutant mais il y
avait besoin de quelqu'un qui pense la
politique globale de Wagner et ça c'est
gagné prix gaugine alors je voudrais que
qu'on qu'on se concentre un petit peu
pendant quelques minutes sur justement
ces liens entre trigogine le groupe
Wagner et le Kremlin Vladimir Poutine
avec d'abord une réaction du président
russe en étant d'octobre 2021 à l'époque
la présence de Wagner en est signalé en
en Afrique ça commence à voilà bruiter
autour de cette question il nie
évidemment avoir des liens avec cette
ministre
c'est une entreprise privée avec des
intérêts privés liés à l'extraction de
ressources énergétiques y compris
diverses ressources comme l'or ou les
pierres précieuses la personne
et pourtant on va regarder un autre
extrait de votre documentaire un ancien
mercenaire de Wagner qui explique à quel
point la ministre dépend du gouvernement
selon les témoins un hélicoptère alors
c'est pas le bon exprès je pense qu'il
va arriver tout de suite donc un
mercenaire vous en avez rencontré pas
mal
il fallait réussir il fallait réussir à
les convaincre donc mercenaire qui
témoigne des liens entre l'État russe et
les ministres Wagner on doit la voir
et cette armée aujourd'hui elle peut
agir sans l'accord du gouvernement
elle ne peut pas elle est totalement
équipée par le gouvernement
les hommes qui sont mobilisés sont
souvent des réservistes de l'armée
ils sont équipés de tout le nécessaire
nourri habillés
sont ceux du ministère de la Défense
mener des opérations de combat
je vous laisse c'est bel et bien une
filiale gouvernementale
une structure de l'État russe une
filiale gouvernementale du covoit une
structure de l'État ils ont que ça
c'était octobre 2021 il tient ses propos
en octobre est-ce que ça a changé
aujourd'hui d'une certaine façon
c'est difficile à dire c'est à dire qu'à
l'origine il faut bien comprendre que le
système russe c'est un système
clientéliste vertical c'est à dire qu'on
a des justement des oligarques qui
doivent prêter allégeance au régime pour
pouvoir effectuer leurs affaires etc ce
que faisait il y avait une trigogine en
plus de ces activités effectivement
militaires là on a la sensation je suis
le qu'il a fait son coming out entre
guillemets depuis qu'il a expliqué que
oui il était bien à la tête de la milice
Wagner et que oui c'était bien lui qui
recrutait depuis des années etc on a la
sensation qui s'échappe un peu qui qui
prend certaines libertés après
effectivement est-ce que on est dans un
rôle une posture qui permet très
potentiellement de montrer que oui on
peut critiquer l'armée russe que
finalement ça n'est pas ce qui
autoritaire que ça ou alors au contraire
est-ce que justement il n'y aurait pas
de grandes difficultés en interne à
contrôler cette personnalité assez
fantasque pour utiliser un mot assez
doux finalement c'est une question qu'on
se pose depuis plusieurs mois de la
capacité de l'animir Poutine à contrôler
gagner
Prigogine
c'est évolutif et évidemment quel est
votre avis là-dessus encore une fois il
faut garder beaucoup d'humilité et
beaucoup de prudence là-dessus parce que
quand bien même on pourrait avoir des
éléments ils peuvent être éminemment
volatiles mais ce que l'on voit c'est
que déjà il y a jamais de critique ou
très peu de critiques direct du
président Poutine que et justement on
revient à la Syrie et aux différents
contrats que vous évoquiez Prigogine
reste très proche de Soro viking qui
fait partie des généraux qui sont à la
manœuvre sur l'opération militaire
spéciale d'ailleurs il l'avait remercié
après le 9 mai quand il avait menacé de
quitter n'avait pas des des éléments et
puis ensuite de revenir donc on a tout
ça si vous voulez dans les vagues
merdiques on a le numéro de matricule
donc
presque dans la milice Wagner il a un
numéro de matricule alors moi je suis un
peu perdu là donc
ça a été en fait il a pris la tête de
l'opération spéciale pendant les trois
mois on a on a il a été dit de manière
un petit peu trop forte qu'il avait été
mis de côté en fin de compte il a été
replacé comme sous geira simov et comme
étant quand même gestionnaire donc très
grosse partie de cette opérations
et vous nous dites que
ce qu'on a vu c'est que depuis la Syrie
ils ont combattu ensemble pour reprendre
Palmyre des mains de daesh et et depuis
la série il a un numéro de matricule
donc chez Wagner quand vous rentrez chez
Wagner vous ne vous appelez plus Thomas
Hugues vous avez un numéro de matricule
qui est le M quelque chose ou ça dépend
maintenant pour l'Ukraine on a changé de
lettre mais c'était le m423 et vous
aviez un nouveau surnom donc le
présentateur par exemple d'accord et
comme ça si on vous retrouvait si on
trouverait on ne pouvait plus on ne
pouvait plus vous retrouver
carrière dans les milices Wagner mais
bon
un contrat chez Wagner on s'engage pour
combien de temps alors ça dépend
ça dépend de l'Ukraine ou de ou d'avant
en fait en Afrique on était sur des
contrats entre 6 mois et deux ans donc
enfin ça pouvait ça pouvait changer on
est sur 6 mois renouvelable mais donc
voilà mais ce que je disais juste pour
terminer sur ce weekend ce qui avait
d'intéressant c'est que donc
on a carrément découvert qu'il avait son
propre numéro de matricule et qu'il
avait la croix noire donc il avait été
récompensé de la plus haute distinction
de Wagner pour combat au sein des
troupes Bagnères ça c'est quand même
incroyable Mathieu je me tourne vers
vous parce que la cette mise Wagner elle
ne se bat pas seulement contre l'Ukraine
elle s'en prend aussi de façon indirecte
à la France oui on en parlait tout à
l'heure c'est surtout l'Afrique ça a
commencé et déjà plusieurs années en
République centrafricaine puis ça s'est
répété au Burkina oumadi enfin voilà et
à chaque fois il y a un scénario bien
rodé qui vise d'abord alimenter une
campagne de propagande anti-française
sur le thème on veut libérer les
Africains du néocolinialisme français
avant de mettre ensuite un pied au
sommet de l'État si possible en
s'accapant la sécurité du régime ou
voilà et puis enfin vous le disiez avec
une forme de prédation de ressources et
on se paye sur la bête que ce soit sur
les mines en Centrafrique ou sur les
richesses qui peuvent trouver ailleurs
et pour le coup tous les moyens sont
bons le financement d'opposant la
présence française qui organise des
manifs la diffusion sur les réseaux
sociaux de clips qui font pas forcément
dans la dentelle mais qui sont largement
relayés sur des comptes soit financés
soit alimenté par toutes ces les fermes
de de
trolls de la sœur Wagner et je vous
montre à propos de clips pour que nos
téléspectateurs une idée le un des
derniers en date
maintenant c'est notre pays
[Applaudissements]
ils sont nombreux je n'ai plus de
munitions
[Musique]
vous imaginez la suite
tous les zombies soldats français nous
sommes les soldats de Macron vont se
faire dessouder par le sauveur de
sauveur le Sauveur donc
ça suffit pas Wagner peut même faire
autre chose ils ont acheté une radio une
des radios principales en Centrafrique
pour diffuser leur propagande et
s'assurer que ça atteigne toutes les
maisons voir il diffuse des fake news
pour cette fois-ci complètement monté
comme l'histoire du fameux charnier de
Gossip donc c'est la découverte d'un
pseudo charnier soi-disant laissé par
l'armée française quand elle a quitté
cette base militaire au Mali ce qui
était une fake news et ce qui était
prouvé par la suite alors comme on est
dans cette guerre informationnelle
comment réagit la France en tout cas
très très mal même je veux dire du point
de vue du résultat si on regarde ça en
termes d'efficacité pour le charnier de
gossis je le disais on a eu des photos
satellites qui montrait que c'était les
musiciens qui avaient creusé les creusé
les creuser les charniers pour mettre
les les cadavres et pas les Français
mais c'est loin d'être suffisant comme
sont loin d'être suffisantes évidemment
les condamnations officielles je vous en
fais écouter une par exemple de notre
ministre d'affaires des étrangères
Catherine Colonna alors cette fois-ci
elle réagissait à une accusation de prix
goji qui imputait à Paris l'explosion
d'un colis piégé en Centre Afrique qui
avait blessé un représentant russe
je vous le dis très
en tout cas les futurs les prochains
États africains qui seraient tentés d'y
recourir ce qui pose une question est-ce
qu'on combat une armée de mercenaires
avec des munitions aussi symboliques
Christine Dubois Clément je pense on
avait déjà fait ce constat sur ce
plateau mais sur la faiblesse de la de
la de la réponse française mais quel
moyen je sais pas si vous avez la
réponse à la question mais quel moyen de
désinformation
Wagner mais mettait en œuvre c'est
beaucoup d'argent c'est beaucoup de
d'hommes c'est des moyens techniques de
comment on peut détailler ça en fait il
faut pas voir uniquement Wagner en tant
que tel mais il faut voir Wagner dans un
écosystème qui va être beaucoup plus
large parce que alors effectivement il y
a les vidéos les dessins animés il y en
avait d'autres vous avez montré à la NBA
qui ciblait beaucoup plus les enfants
j'ai évoqué rapidement des films type
super production donc tout risque granit
etc qui démontre qui présente qui sont
jouées avec des vrais miliciens avec des
locaux enfin il y a quand même des ratés
parfois au niveau des lancements
notamment touristes en Centrafrique la
journée du lancement avait été quand
même un intégrale vous avez un peu trop
vite il lance la vidéo et ça ils ont
lancé le le film mais le pouvoir était
pas vraiment au courant pour voir
centrafricain de ce qu'il y avait dedans
or on présente les forces
centrafricaines comme étant terriblement
lâche étant absolument pas bonne et
heureusement que Wagner est là pour
sauver la femme et l'orphelin alors si
vous voulez avoir une description des
services français comme étant absolument
ignoble et pas loin de la du cafard vous
les avez à peu près dans touristes donc
tout est dépeint de cette façon là si
vous voulez de manière de manière
radicale alors il y a eu aussi beaucoup
de choses c'est que vous avez des vrais
fossiles tank vous avez des fondations
vous avez des ONG sur le continent
africain qui alors qui produisent qui
reprennent qui diffusent sur ces
éléments là vous allez avoir sur les
réseaux sociaux et bien tout un tout des
alors on a parlé des trolls notamment
mais de la production de contenu le but
étant d'arriver à ce que un des un des
un de vos contenus quel qu'il soit soit
repris par un média qui a une influence
ou qui soit sérieux parce que dans ce
cas vous arrivez et bien à tout
simplement lui donner une légitimité et
elle diffuser et il y a quand même une
adaptation si vous voulez du discours un
des contextes locaux c'est à dire qu'on
va reprendre ce que vous allez avoir
alors ça va être l'anti-américanisme
plus d'un côté l'aNTIC colonialisme de
l'autre l'anti français etc pour vous
adapter au contexte que vous allez avoir
et puis enfin il y a des clips y compris
de la musique qui a pu être développé
par par Wagner qui fonctionne donc c'est
un produit marketing complet dans un
écosystème complexe et qui n'est pas
uniquement sur Wagner mais qui est fait
de d'une espèce de constellation
d'éléments plus ou moins démasqués plus
ou moins officiels ou officiers
en Ukraine évidemment c'est à l'oeuvre à
l'Ukraine je voulais justement rajouter
un peu un petit élément pour aller dans
votre sens c'est que cette stratégie
elle est vraiment multi vectorielle et
opportuniste par exemple on parle
beaucoup en ce moment de cet élément de
langage de vladinha Poutine à savoir la
décolonisation le fait que il faut que
l'armée française par du continent
africain que les intérêts français
cessent là-bas etc etc quand on regarde
les statistiques ce mot décolonisation
dans ce contexte là depuis le 24 février
2022 il a été employé par Vladimir
Poutine 36 fois entre 2000 et le 24
février 2022 il l'avait employé 34 fois
donc je sais pas si vous imaginez le la
mutation
et donc il y a vraiment cette idée qu'il
faut utiliser tous les moyens à la
disposition de la Russie pour pouvoir
justement diffuser l'influence russe et
surtout c'est une stratégie aussi
vieille que Machiavel finalement c'est
c'est divisé pour mieux régner
l'objectif c'est de diviser l'Occident
au maximum on sait qu'il y avait eu des
stratégies qui avaient été mises en
place notamment pour l'élection de
Donald Trump même s'il faut minimiser
leur impact on sait que des stratégies
avaient été mises en place aussi pour le
brexit même si à nouveau il faut
minimiser l'impact mais c'était cette
volonté là c'était cette idée là et au
final si on a un Occident des unités
françaises
dans l'élection française il est
tentative il y aurait eu oui il y a eu
des tentatives Emmanuel
macroniques et puis même sur la dernière
présidentielle ils ont on avait
travaillé avec vigilinum l'agence du
secrétariat général de la Défense
nationale donc un service proche du
Premier ministre pour documenter ça que
c'était des services des triji qui avait
monté toute une campagne de faux sites
internet pour c'était incroyable la
stratégie mais c'était pour faire la
promotion d'Emmanuel Macron et comme ça
ensuite dans les médias
différents pays d'Afrique ils disaient
regardé même Macron emploi des trolls en
Afrique c'était un coup de billard à
trois bandes le truc n'a pas marché mais
c'est pour vous dire ils ont quand même
mobilisé beaucoup de gens des cellules
au Bénin en Côte d'Ivoire en
Centrafrique c'était une grosse
opération c'est presque la fin de ce
débat et je voudrais qu'on prenne
quelques minutes pour parler de ce que
des horreurs pratiquées par les certains
ou par les soldats de ces milices Wagner
je vous propose un témoignage une
porte-parole du Haut Commissariat droit
de l'homme de l'ONU qui raconte les
exactions commises alors par des troupes
maliennes et des militaires étrangers au
cours d'une opération en mars 2022 dans
un village du centre du Mali et les
personnes militaires étrangers ont
soupçonne fortement Wagner à écouter là
les témoins un hélicoptère militaire
assurevolé le village en ouvrant le feu
sur la population
tandis que quatre autres hélicoptères
ont atterri et que des troupes ont
débarqué
les soldats ont encerclé les gens dans
le centre du village tirant au hasard
sur ceux qui tentaient de s'échapper au
moins 58 femmes et filles ont été
violées ou soumises à d'autres formes de
violences sexuelles elles sont ajoutés
c'est l'un des enfin c'est ce que vous
racontez aussi dans votre documentaire
des actes de torture notamment
ah bah oui la torture généralisée les
actes de torture les viols sur les
populations locales pour la petite
histoire
les soldats Wagner quand on leur disait
que on avait documenté et interview des
femmes qui avaient été violées ils m'ont
dit c'est pas possible parce que c'est
des femmes noires nous on touche pas au
noir c'est ça leur argument si vous
voulez vous voyez et partout ça a été
mais même encore maintenant on continue
à documenter en Ukraine des soldats qui
nous racontent qu'ils abattent des
femmes et des enfants
oui c'est d'une violence inouïe c'est la
méthode Wagner en fait et pardon mais
ces extraits de des agents de l'ONU me
rend dingue de l'hypocrisie de l'ONU de
parler des personnels militaires
étrangers alors que tout le monde sait
que c'est les Russes que quand le
rapport de l'ONU a mentionné une fois le
mot russe sur la Centrafrique il le
panel d'expert n'a pas été renouvelé
pendant deux ans vous rendez compte de
l'inertie enfin c'est incroyable quand
même de se dire que c'est le poids de la
Russie qui siège mais du coup on est
dans ces cas-là c'est toujours le deux
poids de mesure c'est à dire que vous
êtes au de sécurité on peut rien dire
vous violez vous martyrisez vous tuez
avec des hélicoptères des populations
civiles et on peut même pas dire que et
encore à ce moment là c'était pas une
succursale officiellement c'était un
groupe militaire privé et ben même ça
vous pouvez pas les désigner comme
responsable de ces massacres ça pouvait
permettre effectivement au pouvoir russe
de se débrider en disant privé et voilà
et c'est le problème de l'impunité
totale de ce groupe qui n'a aucune
existence légale on le rappelle du coup
on a beaucoup militer avec Sénia dans
les dans les dans les médias pour dire
que c'était différent de groupe
militaires privés américains parce que
beaucoup de gens nous disaient pourquoi
vous parlez pas le Blackwater l'énorme
différence de Blackwater c'est qu'ils
ont une existence juridique qu'ils ont
commis des crimes de guerre et qui a eu
des procès aux États-Unis pour tous ces
crimes de guerre il n'y a aucun procès
est-ce qu'il n'y a même pas d'existence
légale les gens n'ont n'utilise même pas
leur vrai nom et donc tout notre travail
de journaliste c'est d'essayer de
remonter cette espèce de piste petit à
petit pour retrouver le nom les vraies
identités où sont les gens c'est un
travail de fourmis et ça devrait être
des juges internationaux de faire ça
est-ce que c’est anecdotique mais pas
anecdotique sur le métier de journaliste
est-ce que vous avez été menacé est-ce
que comment vous avez réussi à mener une
enquête comme celle-là et oui on a été
très clairement menacé à plusieurs
reprises notamment sont trafic on a été
suivi nos chambres ont été fouillés des
drones nous surveillaient on a dû partir
précipiterament suite à des menaces
il y a eu des problèmes sur les réseaux
sociaux moi j'ai été arrêté par le FSB
en arrivant à Moscou donc oui les
pressions elles étaient là et maintenant
on a une chance formidable c'est d'avoir
un passeport français et quand même
d'être protégé par notre nationalité
notre passeport ce qui nous a permis de
faire ses enquêtes contrairement on le
rappelle aux journalistes russes qui
sont partis en Centrafrique qui eux ont
été tués et contrairement à notre propre
fixeur qui vit toujours réfugié dans un
autre pays menacé de mort par les gens
de Wagner pour ceux qui ne savent pas ce
sont des personnes qui des gens ils se
locaux qui aident à préparer une enquête
à reportage merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat qui était
passionnant j'ai rappelé Lucas Aubin le
titre de votre livre géopolitique de la
Russie publiée aux éditions de la
découverte de votre documentaire on peut
encore le voir il est disponible et puis
à la suite les vagues merdique sur Arte
qui s'appelle les dossiers de prix
d'origine sur le contenu de l'ordinateur
du bras droit ça merci beaucoup merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce débat je
vous dis à demain pour un nouveau numéro
de sciences publiques vous pouvez
également retrouver les missions tous
les programmes de la chaîne sur notre
plateforme Public Sénat point FR et puis
demain Bruno Retailleau le président du
groupe LR au Sénat sera l'invité Dorian
moscini dans la matinale de Public Sénat
belle soirée à toutes et à tous
[Musique]